(casting)
You know what, guys? Sometimes, you just don’t
give a f@#!.
I’m Colin for theScore esports and this
week on Best of we’re talking about no-holds-barred,
no f@#!s given, CS:GO plays.
Wow.
So what is a no f@#!s given play in CS:GO?
Well, it’s pulling your knife out when you
really know you shouldn’t, it’s sticking
that ninja defuse when you probably should
have just tried to save the gun, it’s pushing
a wall of smokes with nothing but a C-Z and
a dream.
So let's get it started with the most disrespectful
of them all, the knife kill.
(casting)
Nice going boys, you're playing yesterdays tape.
I think I'll go one further on the salutations for s1mple,
I think he's a professor, or doctor s1mple at this point.
I think that's probably fair,
um
he's certainly earned his PhD.
Pretty huge d#@!
(casting)
Look guys, you know how it is.
Sometimes you get
locked behind a wall of smokes, and your brain
says chill, but your heart whispers “push
it”.
(casting)
You know, jumping on that defuse when a molotov
inferno rages beneath you, when bullets are
whizzing past your head, might be stupid,
it might be risky, but hey, you gotta
get on that highlight reel somehow, am I right?
(casting)
Clutch plays are the stuff of magic in CS:GO
and attempting one is risky as hell. But,
sometimes, those cocky, creative attempts
can pay off in the end, and win your
team the round.
(casting)
Alright guys that’s all we’ve got for you this week.
If you’ve got a suggestion for a player, a team or an event you want us to cover
on Best of, let me know
in the comments below, and I’ll see you
next week! But until then, remember, when
it comes to
delivering quality content to you, the viewer,
we really do give a f@#!.